I'M CHRISTI PAUL.
>> AND I'M VICTOR BLACKWELL.
>> AN ISIS LEADER HAS BEEN
KILLED IN A U.S. DRONE STRIKE.
30 OTHERS WERE KILLED IN THE
COMPOUND AS WELL.
THE FORMER TALIBAN LEADER IS
BELIEVED TO HAVE JOINED ISIS.
WE'LL BRING IN LIEUTENANT
COLONEL JAMES REESE.
COLONEL, I WANT TO IDENTIFY WHO
THIS MAN WAS.
THERE WAS A MAN WHO HAD A $10
MILLION BOUNTY ON HIS HEAD.
DO WE KNOW IF THIS IS THE SAME
PERSON?
>> GOOD MORNING, CHRISTI.
THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON, THIS
STRIKE HAPPENED TWO DAYS AGO IN
AFGHANISTAN.
INTELLIGENCE WAS BROUGHT IN BY
THE AFGHAN NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
THE SECURITY, THE NDS.
IT IS A VERY CAPABLE SECURITY
AND INTELLIGENCE AGENCY FOR
PRESIDENT GHANI AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE ABDULLAH.
THERE WERE REPORTS THAT THE SAME
GENTLEMAN FROM THE PAKISTAN AREA
CAME OVER TO JOIN ISIS AND
KILLED HIMSELF BY PLACING AN
IED.
WE'LL SEE WHAT SHAKES OUT HERE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
>> EVERYTHING IS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
HOW BIG OF A BLOW COULD THIS BE
TO ISIS?
>> IT'S A BIG PIECE FOR ISIS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THEIR MOVEMENT
INTO OTHER AREAS, ESPECIALLY
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS THAT I
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KEEP
THEIR EYES ON AFGHANISTAN WITH
ALL THE AMERICAN FORCES THERE,
STILL TRYING TO SUPPORT THE
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT.
THE TALIBAN BORDER BETWEEN
PAKISTAN AND AFGHANISTAN, A LOT
ARE DISILLUSIONED AND NOT
SUCCESSFUL PUSHING BACK TO
KABUL.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
FIND A NEW BANNER TO FLY AND WE
ARE SEEING THAT IN AFGHANISTAN
WITH THE ISIS FLAG.
SO IF THIS STRIKE IS CONFIRMED,
BECAUSE BACK IN APRIL IT WAS
NEVER CONFIRMED THAT HAMIZ WAS
KILLED.
IT WILL BE A BIG BLOW